here are my four proofs for congruence
and then for similarity okay now really
quickly I'm not gonna draw the pass
because the whole point is like if
they're the same then I don't need to
draw it once and then exactly the same
again right so congruence is if you have
a pair of triangles right if I have
three sides right that exactly match up
that's an SSS proof and the
corresponding crude for similarity is
you still have three pairs or sign the
correspond but they just look equal it
is in proportion like all of these of
the twice's being as that for all of
them are three times as big as that
similarity SAS means you're going to get
two sides and the included angle now
this is the shortest way I've ever
encountered of saying it okay
science so it says plural so you're
gonna get more pensive science than just
the one right about which is meant to be
sort of the opposite of included an
angle can be included by two sides and
the sides can be about the angle right
so that is a technical word not like
just about it means the opposite
included
besides about the equal angles if
they're in proportion your group a a s
were familiar with this one right you
can have two angles which means you
really have all the angles
that's equiangular once you have a side
then you've locked in the size of the
triangle right so no longer are they
like similar to each other but if one of
the sides is the same length then
they're exactly the same size and then
there's this awkward RHS one down the
bottom here okay now there's a reason
why he's the poor cousin of this whole
lot because if you are HS let's just
quickly have a look about this looks
like so yes its life is alpha cos beta
and any of the science is fine now what
would this look like so you've got a
right angle triangle that's a given
okay and then you have the hypotenuse
that's the H right angle I pop music and
you have one of the other sides okay now
hold on a second I mean this is a right
angle triangle if you know like we
usually call the size a B and C if you
know a and C it is trivial to work out B
right
like you can just do Pythagoras and
you've got all three sides and then you
just say this rather than this mouthful
okay so it's there the reason why it's
works is because it implies this one
once you have the hypotenuse and shorter
side of a right angle triangle you have
all the sides now just a quick note to
again Ram home because it's such an easy
thing to do when you're approving SAS
SAS is the most picky because it needs
the included angle okay that's it
illustrate why rather than just like
moving stores around which you can't do
it is fun mathematically proving like
rigorously why you need the include
angle is because of a situation like
this you remember our old friend the
sign moon right this sign room would be
able to tell us what theater is right
help me wake it up
what would I run trying to find theta
sine theta sorry 3 sine 30 degrees on
one you're happy with that just this on
this this on this okay let's cut it a
little bit so I've got sine theta over
here root 3 is going to go away huh
and then sine 30 of course is uh-huh
so what I've got over here is root 3 on
2 okay but you have been trained to
avoid the side rule and use the cosine
rule wherever you possibly can because
at this point you have to be careful you
have to say what you have to say could
be this equals right what's what's your
base angle what's the first time the
reticular references it's 60 degrees
sine of course that's only one of the
things it could be right it can also be
a hundred twenty there's an acute
version and there is and a tous version
now what would this look like 60 degrees
well clearly that's the one I've kind of
looks like that's not the one I really
want
this theta is obtuse so if the diagram
were to scale which it's not but on this
diagram that's got to be the 120 case
you see right what would that case look
like you still got the root 3 you still
got the 30 degrees but if you want this
to be side length 1 and you want an
angle of 60 degrees over here right then
you have to take this guy further so
that it comes over to here sorry my
scale not very good but you see now this
is an acute angle and I still love my
one another way of seeing this is it's
the same triangle but I flipped this
side this way see that okay now have a
look at these two triangles that I have
just drawn ok and for a second forget
the fact that we actually know what
theories ok if I get rid of theta
I have side side side side angle angle
but because the angle is not included
these triangles are completely different
they're not congruent right the reason
they are not congruent and they can't be
unless it's included is because this
sign rule will give you two triangles
right that are different to each other
they won't be congruent if you try and
get similes and there won't be similar
if you've got links that are in
proportion okay so in fact you know the
funny thing about this is you you
discover this before you know what the
sign rule is okay so we just say because
otherwise you'll be in trouble but now
you know enough mathematics to know why
you actually can get to non congruent
triangles even when you seem to have so
much information that winds up you don't
have the information in the right spots
to guarantee that all the features will
line up
correct okay happy that so by the way
just in case you're curious because you
can see right this creates the familiar
30-60-90 triangle and this creates an
isosceles triangle which is going to be
different okay so very very different
beings because of this sign